okay so we're going to be talking about
data for your research organism i'm
peter cooper of adelaide rhodes and i
are uh doing teamwork on this one
so i'm going to introduce sort of a
topic and she's going to take over to
show you um how we can get these data
together in a jupiter notebook after i
go over a few things preliminarily
okay so today we decided to focus on uh
this organism this is a tree species the
black cottonwood populous trichocarpa
it's a fast-growing forestry that's
native to western north america
it's used in pulp and lumber
it has a pretty compact genome which is
kind of useful
450 million base pairs or so and you
know although we say this is kind of for
non-model organisms this is a potential
model tree genome
so here's what we're going to do today
we're going to
basically explore and retrieve data for
this organism we're going to look at the
genome assembly we're going to gather
some gene information and we're going to
particularly look at
a suite of genes called the nac domain
containing transcription regulators
these are important for plant
development and so if you were
interested in conditions and how they
affect gene expression these would be
genes that you'd be interested in
looking at
in terms of gene expression we're going
to look at some expression data in the
form of rna-seq so that's next-gen
sequencing reads from sra and will
ultimately wind up looking at the effect
of drought response on gene expression
once we collect all that information you
know then you would need to analyze that
and adelaide is going to do a demo using
command line tools that she's got into a
workflow setup and a jupiter notebook
and she will analyze these data
and we'll put them in a genome browser
for you to analyze and see the
expression data
mapped across the genome
so just to introduce that topic and to
show you uh to introduce some of the
resources i'm going to do some of this
on the web and on the web we're going to
visit the assembly database and the data
sets which is a tool associated with
assemblies and we'll use that to get the
genome assembling annotation
we're going to use the gene database to
get the genes that we're interested in
find their locations in particular
because that's what we're going to do
with them at the end uh and we'll go to
sra and we'll get the submitted next-gen
sequencing data the rna-seq data is what
we're going to be looking at today
and we'll use a tool associated with sra
called the run selector
to help to sort through the kinds of
sequencing reads that we have there to
get the ones that are of interest then
finally we're going to use the genome
browser
genome data viewer to
load the data at the end of the talk to
see the analysis that we've done in the
context of the genome
and so to do that analysis we're going
to use command line tools we're going to
use the command line version of data
sets
to download the data
in the jupyter notebook
we're going to use the sre toolkit to
access the
rna-seq data
and we're going to use magic blast to
align the rna-seq data to the genome
so we can see the kinds of
expression changes that we see over the
course of experiments
uh the last command line tool which
isn't really um
an ncbi tool but it's called samtools
and that's something that you're gonna
need to if you're gonna need to have
installed if you're gonna work with
alignment files like the kind you're
gonna get from magic blast
okay
so with that what i'm going to do is go
over to the ncbi website
and that's the url there and i'm just
going to run through a quick demo on the
website about how to how to get some of
these data and then we'll switch over to
the jupiter notebook and adelaide
and i'll go to the ncbi homepage here
and the first thing i'm going to do is
just do a search for the name of the
organism and i'm going to do what's
called an all databases search
this is a way to search all ncbi
databases at once we've put some
convenient
search sort of interrupters in there so
if you search with something like the
name of an organism we have a pop-up
that shows up and says hey it looks like
you're looking for the name of an
organism here's some here's a way to get
the information about that organism and
here's a way
to get some data
so
what i get here is a hit to the taxonomy
database that's where you could go to
get some information about how we
classify this organism at ncbi and you
can link out from there to all the
different resources where we have data
for this organism we also have some
shortcuts here that let you get some of
that data directly
without having to go there
so we're going to take a look at two of
these um let's take a look at this one
where it says browse and download
getting genomes for populous trichocarpa
and that's going to take me to datasets
this is the datasets genome browser
and you can see
that it's got three different genome
assemblies for you here
the one at the top is the
reference genome the ncbi reference
genome
with its annotation
and we can go ahead and download that if
we want i'll just mention what these
other two are the one at the bottom
is the genbank submitted
uh genome assembly and the one in the
middle is the previous refseq assembly
so we take the genbank submitted
assembly and we annotated itself so if
we go here and we download this let me
check that box there and i'll go to the
download button up here on the right
hand side
i can get
all different aspects of this genome
i'll get i can get the genomics fasta
two different sort of feature files
which show me how the thing is annotated
um i can get the transcripts and the
protein sequences these are all based on
ncbi's eukaryotic genome annotation
pipeline
for the purposes of today let's go ahead
and download
the genomics fasta so that's going to
give me a fasta sequence for each one of
the chromosomes and then i can get this
gff3 file which gives me the
annotated features so if i want to i can
name my file i can press this download
link here and that will just download a
package for me with all that data in it
just press that for a second so you can
see that i could just download this
directly if i wanted to and it gives me
a zip file that has all that data in it
so that's one of the things we're going
to need to do our analysis today
i'm going to go back
to get back to the center and i'm going
to jump ahead in a way i'm jumping to
the end of the
demonstration today but i just want you
to see this so if i wanted to look at
this genome in the genome data viewer
which is our genome browser i could just
follow this link here
and because i've looked at this gene
before the genome data viewer remembers
what i did and this actually happens to
be one of the genes that we're going to
be looking at today this is one of these
um
genes that has that
domain in it
and if i want to i can go to gene here
before i do that and that's what i'm
going to do i just want to point out to
you that
we already have aligned
some
nextgen sequencing data to this
these are the data that we use from sra
to annotate this genome so we use these
rna-seq data here
to get some gene models for this and
that's basically how we annotate this
particular gene
so with that in mind let's go ahead and
move to gene now
and of course we'll come back to this
view later on when we align our own
next-gen data that we found the genome
let's go ahead and go over here to gene
so i'm just going to click through to
the gene record
and so as promised this is one of these
no nac domain containing protein genes
and this is a typical gene record for an
organism where we don't have a lot of
information if this was a human gene
we'd have a lot more
things linked in here this is sort of
the one-stop shop if you know what gene
you're looking for you would come here
to find out more information about it
we can also use gene to get
all the genes for the
for the black cottonwood or a particular
set of genes so let's just do that
search that we did before right here in
the gene database
and i get my
pop up again with my ad
but i also can see the number of genes
that we have for black cottonwood here
below there's 37
273 genes
i can filter these down to get a set
that i might be interested in so i can
add i can click on this genomic filter
here
that means that these are genes that are
in the
these are chromosomal genes are not
things that are associated with the
organelles and i might be interested
only in protein coding genes i can do
that here
and so now i have 30 000 genes about the
same number as the protein coding genes
for the human genome
and i could add something to my search
if i want to
i could add that nac domain search if i
want to let's see what we get if we do
that
so i could make this more precise if i
wanted to i could say you know nac
domain containing protein and that might
even be
more precise than this but it looks like
i'm getting a lot of things that are of
interest here
and let's narrow this set down there's
116 of these genes with that kind of
description
let's narrow this down a little bit more
let's just get all these kinds of genes
that are on chromosome 5. and what we'll
do
when we align these things you know
we'll look at particularly look at
chromosome 5 just to give us a smaller
set of data so here's another filter
that i can add
and let's add chromosome locations let
me show that filter
i'll go ahead and click more
and i'll click on black cottonwood it
doesn't matter which one of these i
picked that's the common name that's
scientific name
let's pick chromosome five
apply that
and it takes a minute
and so i get 10 of these genes on
chromosome 5. so if we wanted to browse
these across the genome in the genome
data viewer which we will do later on we
can look at perhaps changes in the gene
expression of these genes
in different treatments of some kind of
experiment with rna-seq
so what we want to do now is to find the
rna-seq experiment that we're going to
work with and so i'm going to change
databases here let me just take that nac
domain off of there
let me change the database to sra sra
stands for the sequence read archive and
that's where that's our repository of
next-gen sequencing data we'll go ahead
and run the search there
and i get 2700
experiments basically and most of these
experiments are one sequencing run
sometimes there's more than one
i know that i'm interested in expressed
sequences so i can use the filter over
here to get rna
so i now have 1800 rna seek experiments
and i could you know click on every one
of these and read through what the
experiment was and all that stuff but
it's kind of awkward to do in this way
and it's also true that because these
are submitted data
the kinds of information that people
provide to us varies a lot and so it's
kind of hard to sort through them in
this interface
there's a better way to work with these
data and that's the run selector
and so i'm going to throw these all into
the run selector
which is a good way of looking at the
various kinds of data metadata that
people provide about their experiments
and then i can use that to sort of sort
down to the experiments that i want to
look at
okay
so here they all are
and there's a bunch there's a table down
here that has all these different
columns
center name you can see them here it
goes on for quite a ways sometimes
there's nothing in that column
they didn't give us that information
you can scroll across and see there's a
whole lot of potential information here
sometimes it's filled out sometimes it's
not and i can actually select by those
columns to see how we can split the data
up into various things so
let's just look at the various columns
that we could have here
so for example here's a simple one i can
see what country the geographic location
was listed
so we have canada
uncalculated china and usa
and most of them don't have that
information on
them or relevant to what we're trying to
do today might be something like
drought treatments or things like that
so here's an interesting
set days after drought treatment let me
check that
and there are
three different treatments
a zero day five day and seven days so i
can go ahead and ask to see all those
so now i have a set of data that might
be interesting to work with we have four
sets
of samples um from each of the
treatments and i might want to look at
the expression of some of those genes
that we saw a few minutes ago
at these different days of drought
treatment
now
let me go ahead and
select all these now how can i get these
data well
if i'm working in a situation where i
can get them delivered i could get them
delivered to the cloud if i want to
um or i could get them delivered to a
galaxy workflow
what we're going to do is to get them
with the toolkit
and in order to do that we need to get
the
what we really need to do that is to get
the accession numbers
so there's only 12 of them
if i had hundreds of them it might be
particularly useful to download it and
notice that i can download this entire
table or i can download the accession
list
if i click here all i basically get is a
list of
a text file that has those
12 accession numbers in them and
adelaide's going to use that information
in a few minutes to align these to the
genome okay so let me switch back to my
slides
because we're going to shift gears now
and we're going to use these data in a
juker notebook
in a workflow
so basically what's going to happen is
we're going to use the same set of data
that i just showed you but we're going
to
incorporate them into this
workflow so we're going to download
those sra runs
and we're going to use the sra toolkit
and a
function in there or a program there
called fastq dump to get that data out
of sra format
we're also going to download the
assembly using the datasets command line
tool
and then we're going to use a tool
called magicblast
and we'll go ahead and use magicblast to
align those
next-gen sequencing data to the genome
and that will tell us like you know what
genes they match
and we'll process that alignment data
with samtool so that we can
upload it into the genome data viewer
and look at expression across the genome
and also across those different
treatments so what i'm going to do now
is change presenter and give this to
adelaide let her take over for a while
great can everyone hear me okay great oh
good so this is a notebook for those of
you who may not be familiar with
notebooks it's just a way to show
command line and let people practice on
it
so we have actually provided a link to a
live notebook that if you want to
reproduce this analysis
you can do it from anywhere in the world
because a binder notebook will spin up a
small server somewhere else all you need
is a web browser
so anyway we're inside the notebook and
i did change the order a little bit
we're going to get the sra runs first
and then we're going to get the assembly
and then run magic blast before we load
stuff into the viewer
so here uh these are the four steps
we're going to follow and then if you do
choose to download this notebook so you
can get it just by hitting download here
you would need to install a few programs
onto the machine where you might be
running this
but um basically the way notebook works
is you have just your code blocks and
you hit run and then it runs a little
bit of code so the cool thing about this
is that i can write one notebook but for
use it for many different analyses
so i have gone ahead and started
looking for data that's related to our
sra run so remember we had an accession
list that was output so this was the
first accession in the accession list
and i'm using the sra toolkit tool
called fastq
so this is the actual command line so
the way notebooks work also is you can
run bash commands linux commands
by just putting an exclamation point in
front of the command so if you actually
just wanted to do this on command line
you would copy this piece of the code
put it in a terminal and you would be
able to run it if you've installed sra
toolkit
so the new sra toolkit just a little bit
about this code block does require a
little bit of configuration but it's
easy to do it interactively or you can
use just a little bit of code to get it
started running what the purpose of that
is is that we're on the cloud and cbi
has moved 18 petabytes of publicly
available data
that's not controlled up to aws so
sra toolkit needs to know where you are
and how you want to access the data so
it'll default to the free buckets in aws
so i ran this command i asked for the
first two lines in a fastq format from
this particular sequency run and as you
can see i'm not going to
run the code cells live because they
take a few minutes so i've i've pre-run
them but this is the expected output you
would see the first two lines of the
fastq file
all right but i don't just want two
lines i want to actually do an analysis
here so what's my strategy well i'm
going to have to do something called
batch which means i send a whole bunch
of numbers into the program to run and
so there's different ways of doing this
and you know i've been doing bash for a
long time so i apologize if you're not
familiar with these commands but there's
many ways to do this so the first thing
you need to do is have a list of your
accession so this is the list that peter
downloaded
and i'm saying open it up so cat just
means open up the list and do something
with it and then
you would send it to another command so
this little up and down line is called a
pipe and it sends it into the next
command where i'm saying i've got 12 of
these files to run
let's run fastq dump but this is a small
machine i don't want to get all the data
i'm just doing like a preliminary survey
of what's in it
so i only want a million lines so i'm
getting a million lines for each of
these accessions and i'm putting it into
an output folder called data so i've
like i said i've already run it
it took about three minutes to run this
command and so after the
command is finished running i've got a
nice little data folder filled with fast
q files that are a million lines each
okay
the next stage is going to go and get
the reference genome so our data sets
group at ncbi has spent a lot of time
building command line and
python and our versions of their tools
so i i like bash so all my commands in
this notebook are written in bash
for the most part and so um
what you can do is download and install
a program and it's called data sets and
when you call data sets you can tell it
to do a lot of different things like
download genes but i would like to
download a genomic session right so i
actually have the genomic session number
we were looking at in the web browser
and i only want chromosome five so i've
already
incorporated that into how i'm
downloading it and i do want the gtf
file but i don't really want the protein
pasta or the transcriptome fasta i just
care about the annotations
and just fyi the gff is included
automatically so you have to exclude it
you have to opt out of that
all right so that command runs and gives
you a zipped data file so just for my
convenience because i might be running
many of these analyses i've renamed the
file upon output
so what i've got is um an unzipped of
the file which came down as ncbi
dataset.zip by default and then i'm
renaming it into directory for populist
trichocarpa and i call it refseq so i
remember that this is the refseq dataset
and then as you can see it outputs
several different files
but the one i really care about and what
i'm going to use in the next step is the
chromosome fast a file the nucleotide
version of the fasta file is what dot
fna means
okay great so i've done the first two
steps i've gotten my fastq files set up
i've got my reference genome i'm ready
to align so here's another chance to
highlight an ncbi tool
called magic blast magic blast differs a
little bit from
other aligners in that you do not index
the genome what you actually do
is make a blast database of your target
fasta file the thing you want to align
to so i've done that up here i've made a
blast database using the blast plus
tools which are loaded into my computer
here and have generated a mini blast
database just for chromosome five
um it's nucleotide and so now i'm going
to be able to use magic blast or
regular blast any kind of blast like
it's just making a blast database for
whatever downstream purposes i want
so how does this all work
well
magicblast will take his input your
reads and you could give them directly
from sra you don't have to make them
into fastq files but the reason i'm
doing fastq files today is because
they're smaller and i know they'll run
in the amount of time and memory that i
have available on this little mini
machine
the
default output is going to be sam files
so sam files are really useful also but
i am i know that i'm going to need bams
for loading to the genome viewer so that
most genome viewers require a bam output
to load so i go ahead and make a little
directory called bams
i set my
machine virtual memory limits by just
limiting the amount of bases analyzed at
one time by magic blast that's all that
this tells you but you wouldn't have to
do this if you want a larger machine
um and then i start the command so for
those of you not really familiar
with uh command line what you get is you
have a command and then you generally
have a bunch of parameters that say
what what data sets do i want to analyze
with this command so you usually have a
query data set so i'm just running one
file here i'm just picking one of the
fastq files i made in the last step
i'm saying what database do i want to
analyze it against and so that would be
the
blast database we just made
and then you can get some other
parameters such as splice
let it be true because
it is transcriptomic data
i say no unaligned just to save space
because the sam file won't retain reads
that weren't aligned and then i have to
tell it it's a fast q file and then once
again i'm trying to conserve virtual
memory on a small machine but you
wouldn't have to set that uh parameter
there the maxdb count all this
information is available in the links up
at the top of this notebook so you'll be
able to do more exploration on how all
this works later on
and then as i mentioned we need to use
sam tools to convert it into bam so i go
ahead and use the little you know pipe
tool again to um start sending the data
that's made by magic glass into a bam
file and then after i'm done i just have
to index it and then
from command line i've never had to go
back to the web or look at anything on
the web except maybe getting the
accession number for the reference
genome
um and and getting accession numbers for
run selector i've been able to do all of
this in the notebook so now i've got
a bam and an index spam and that brings
us back to the web where we're able to
view our files by loading them as remote
files
so i'm going to click on this link here
and go into the web browser to show you
three of the files that i've already
preloaded for you
so um this is the viewer that peter was
showing you but now
i i'm sharing with you a pre-loaded set
of files from
the um treatments that we just did an
analysis
from so i picked one file from day zero
one file from day five and one file from
day seven
this was one of the nac domain
containing proteins and as you can see
there is a difference in
what the bam outputs for each of these
treatments so
it's a little bit deceptive but you see
little numbers here because these
viewers are adaptive so they adjust the
height to like the amount of data that
you have in your bam file but in order
to actually know the true number you
kind of have to look here so you've got
you know two it's a log two scale two
reads on average aligned you know 100
reads on average aligned and 42 reads on
average aligned you know to
the same reference genome but on day
zero five and seven so you can see
there's a little bit of an upregulation
a little bit of a down regulation if i
wanna see the tracks
i can just go here from adaptive view to
show all
okay and there are no tracks for that
one right it only had one or two but um
you'll see here
there's a lot of cool things and
features like built into genome viewer
so i don't we have lots of webinars on
those also so i'm not gonna like belabor
it but you can kind of see here that by
looking at all the tracks i can kind of
distinguish that there's a lot going on
on day five that wasn't happening on day
zero so that's kind of the beauty of
doing
an analysis from a notebook and then
straight into the viewer it just saves
you time and then you're not having to
download a lot of stuff to your computer
directly
you can just kind of stream it all
and then if you want to add
another
track here it's simply a matter we
already kind of gave you publicly
available tracks
so that it would be less lift for people
who aren't really familiar with this
technology before but just to give you
like a little bit of a taste for it but
you could certainly generate your own
bams and index bands
and um bam index sorry bam indexes and
then put them into your
github and then just kind of copy and
paste them over from the github so i
give you the format down there on how to
do that if you don't have an ftp site
but
just it's really easy because we have
the ftp site set up and these files
remain public to you
um we can add another remote file
from another
sample here
and we added the trick is you have to
have the bam file and the um bam indexed
file in the same directory for it to
recognize and upload it so you can see
uh
the new one i loaded comes up at the
bottom
right yeah oh no wait 37 is the the new
one
yeah so it's right here so the new one
came up here i'm not sure how that works
but you can you can reorder you can move
things around so you can see here that
on day seven in this particular sample
it wasn't that exciting either so just
looking at one sample as you know is not
enough so you could probably do some
more downstream analysis looking at
counts and averaging counts across the
different treatments so they get a
really true view of what's going on but
if you're just
interested to know whether this genes
being expressed in your genome in a
particular rna-seq data set this is
a notebook that will help you um
accomplish that
okay and that's kind of all i had to say
about that
and peter how do i handle
so don't don't hand it over to me yet
because i there's a there's a question
that i think is best answered by just
showing them in the notebook
so one question was what what's all the
software that you needed
and so i think you made a list of that
at the top of the notebook right so on
what you're required to do for that so
you could just
put it here with the install
instructions linked
okay and just in terms of the notebook
um
and i'll show you a slide in a minute
that has the link on it too and
the notebook is the the notebook
file itself is in that ftp directory
that i sent to you
um including and also the slides that i
presented also that's where all those
bams are that and the index files that
adelaide was loading the other thing is
that you can you can run the same
notebook if i'm correctly understanding
this by going to binder and running it
yourself there correct adelaide
um yes this is all on a binder this is a
publicly available live notebook that
all you need is a web browser to get to
so we do provide the link to that in our
presentation slides and i'll switch back
to those now just to show you all those
links
so this is a set of websites here that
that we talked about today but that that
compressed url right there in that last
slide
will take you to that jupiter notebook
on binder where you could run it
yourself um
if you wanted to
and then here's some links to things
about i've already covered some of these
in the slides
another question adelaide that i'll i'll
let you help me answer
you know
to run the jupyter notebook you need
some kind of environment to run it so
for example if you were going to run
this on windows you'd need something
like anaconda correct
yeah they would have to set up a
notebook on the machine uh that they
want to run it on so
yeah that that would require some more
installs and things like that that's why
i made the binder available because for
people who don't know how to do that
stuff they can still run with run the
notebook or like i said you can just
copy the commands and take off the
exclamation point and run them straight
from terminal
and they should work if you've installed
all the software right and so in that
case you could install all this software
on on either a linux or a windows
machine you just have to go through the
steps of installing it but you to have
the
jupyter notebook environment you'd have
to have some kind of environment that
will run that
and there's there are programs that
install on windows that'll do that
anaconda's one of them
another question that that i'll answer
and wayne actually answered this too
somebody pointed out i think they know
about magicblast but
in order to you know
adelaide had
used fast q dump to actually bring the
data locally that was basically just to
show you that you could do that because
you may need to use those fast q files
in some other application
but it is true that magic blasts can
actually act as a client and go to ncbi
or in actually i think it's in the cloud
it knows that it will get them from the
cloud bucket but so all you have to do
is give it the accessions directly and
it will it'll run it that way too so
that's right that that's another way to
run it if your only purpose was to run
magic blast that might be an easier
thing to do just the point was to try to
show you that you can
use the sra tool cat toolkit to bring
that data locally
okay and i think i think we've answered
all the questions that we had in there
i think that's a wrap everybody
thank you for coming and i'll go ahead
and end the webinar for everybody thanks
adelaide and thanks wayne and we'll talk
to you next time
thank you peter